hey everyone welcome back today we're
gonna be talking about what I think is a
largely neglected part of playing the
guitar and that is warming up
[Music]
whether you're a classical guitarist a
metal guitarist or I don't know somebody
who plays the Beach Boys in their
basement all day you could benefit from
a proper warmup now when we think of
warming up we think about literally
getting our fingers warm and of course
that is a part of it you know if you're
coming in from the cold weather and
you're about to play a concert you do
need to actually warm up your hands
because they'll be a little little stiff
but more importantly today I'm going to
teach you about the real importance of
warming up
[Music]
when we play songs there's too much
going on to focus on technique technique
is all about the mechanism of playing so
how you're positioning your body the
placement of your fingers how your
fingers are actually moving in the first
place
the real importance of warming up is to
allow ourselves the opportunity to
examine our technique in a
hypersensitive way with very patient
slow exercises that will give you the
opportunity to really pay attention to
how you're moving to how you're playing
and to then improve your technique so
today I'm gonna give you a few exercises
that you can take with you and start
your practice session with and again
whether you're playing folk pop rock
metal it doesn't matter use these and if
you do you'll see stunning results in
the long run because the more solid your
technique is the better you are at
playing whatever music it is that you
want to play ok we are ready to warm up
and we're going to start with people who
play with a pick and then we'll move to
people who play with their fingers I
think it's great to do each hand
individually because at least we take
out the problem of sinking up the hands
so this one can this one can chill let's
start with a very simple exercise which
has to do with memorizing the spacing of
the strings very often I hear guitarists
making mistakes because the right hand
missed the string so it's very simple we
play four notes on every string and then
three two and then one remember that we
were going to keep a slow pace because
warming up should be a very hyper
sensitive mindful activity where you're
examining under a microscope how you're
moving and you see if you can make it
easier so here's the exercise we start
with fours
Rebecca
[Music]
feel free to look at your hand if you
want and if you if you feel comfortable
you don't have to look at it then we go
to threes and you go back up of course
each time so make sure when you're doing
this that you're always alternating down
up down up down up down up even if
you're playing threes it's down up down
up down up down down up down down let me
move on to twos 1 2 1 2 2 etc ones are
kind of fun because it's very Skippy 1 1
so that's a great warm-up for the right
hand with a pick if you're a classical
guitarists and you're working on
alternation this is our main way of
playing is with the index and middle
fingers and we can put our thumb on the
6th string and we can start with em
playing rest strokes where we play a
string and we rest on the adjacent
string above it so here we're gonna go
middle index middle index and it'll just
keep going I'll call it M I M I so same
exercise for s 3 s 2 s once
[Music]
three Sarah twos and the very fun one
once now I'm going a bit fast to show
you the examples but I would strongly
encourage you to go at your own pace
there's no such thing as too slow
everyone play is too fast this would be
a great time to break out your metronome
don't be afraid to go one two three four
and really study the movement of the
fingers okay the left hand is being
impatient and it wants to join in on the
fun
so the left hand can join in with an
exercise called a spider crawl and this
one if you're a guitarist plays with a
pick you can use the pick if you play
with your fingers you can use your
fingers spider crawl is going to get the
left hand involved and the way it works
is you start at the twelfth fret on the
first string we're going to use our art
pinky to do that and then we go 12 11
and now to notice that I used a
different finger for each one of those
notes and then we moved the hand one
fret to the left and again we started
the pinky but this time on the 11th fret
11 10 9 8 and we move one over again 10
9 8 7 and on where we go
[Music]
we go all the way down this can be done
in every single string including the 6th
all the way down when you're playing
this I would suggest going very slow
something like one note per second you
can say one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi if it helps you you
can also remind yourself of a few
important tips the first is try to keep
your fingers close to the strings try to
avoid this type of thing very common at
the beginning try to keep those fingers
nice and close the next thing is inside
of a fret here's the first fret we have
lots of room and we can play on the left
side the middle or even the right side
often I see people playing randomly of
play on the right side of the fret not
on top of the metal because it mutes the
note if you play just barely to the left
of the metal part it's the perfect
sounding note it's the most in tune the
easiest to play and the least buzzy on
the left side we get this unpleasant
buzzy sound so we can think about those
things while we play on the right side
of the frets and keep your fingers close
to the strings etc next I like to do a
chromatic scale which is going to use
all six strings in first position to do
this you can use again a pick or your
fingers I'll use a pick this time
just remember to alternate it's the best
way to play to do this one we're going
to start on the sixth string and we're
going to play zero one two
for same thing in the next string zero
keep going 0 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 and
backwards remembering we're in no rush
there's nowhere to be we're trying to
study our hand and improve all the way
down okay guys it's just three simple
exercises and if you start your day like
that I guarantee you'll find greater
ease and you're playing independent of
whatever music you're trying to play the
guitar is gonna make more sense to you
and you'll have an easier time playing
thanks for watching I hope you subscribe
if you haven't already you'll get
notified when I make new videos like
this for with more tips and videos
playing also stay tuned I have an
introducing series where I'm going to be
teaching you all about strange and rare
plucked instruments from the past thanks
for watching see you next time
you
[Music]